So now it's time to actually implement
the changes we talked about in
the last video.
To start with,
I'm going to open the create screen
in an image editing software.
I'm going to use Paintbrush,
a free image editing software for
Macs, but feel free to use
whatever software you like.
So for me, I will go up here,
go to open, and
browse my way to the correct screen.
So now that I'm here,
what we're seeing is that we
have this event language here.
And everywhere else in the class,
we use this language of task,
so the first task for us will be
to change this event word to task.
Now, it's fairly easy to do
that in a program like this.
I am actually just going to copy this,
command c, command v and cover that up.
It's not the cleanest, but it works.
And with, as with all prototyping,
what works is what you should be doing.
So let's move this event
word from the screen.
Now, we need to add the task
word to the screen.
So this won't be ideal, but
it will actually convey the information
we're trying to convey.
So, now that I've done that,
I can save and then I can close out.
If we wanted to upload this,
that my prototype was now using it,
we would press this plus button.
See how it says drag and drop?
We can simply go up to create,
drag that and drop that.
And because it has the same name,
we now have task over here.
Any time you're uploading a screen to
your InVision prototype, which has
the exact same name as a previous
screen, it will override that screen.
So, now when I go into this
screen that we've just created,
then I go to the build mode, you'll
see that it already has these hotspots,
and so it already knows
that it's supposed to link backslash
close when I press the create button.
Now let's think another thing.
If we want to have these check
boxes show up somewhere and
they need to be good, well,
the first place we encountered
check boxes was this calendar day.
So let's open up this calendar day
in our image editing software.
So as we can see, it currently has
these check boxes, which are these
grey circles, and then they turn into
blue circles with checks in them.
That was confusing some of our users so,
again,
we're just going to cover this up.
There's no need to be fancy with it,
and then we'll replace that.
So I like Paintbrush because it
comes with this nice tool for
just putting out rounded boxes.
So I can just make
this square check box.
I'm holding the Shift key down to
make sure that it's actually square.
And then I can switch over
to this copying tool again,
grab that, and copy it on down.
I'm going to try and line these up, but
they won't be perfect,
and that's all right.
Again, you want the least time spent
on your prototype as possible.
So again, we've cleaned this up, it's
much better, we have these check boxes,
let's save and upload that screen.
So again, click this plus button,
and move the calendar day on over.
So by doing that, we've now got
these check boxes here, and
we've now got all of the hotspots
already there, so we can click on this
and go to the week or the month,
create an event, go back to this drawer.
The final thing we wanted to do
was make sure that the home screen
had these check boxes, and
we can do that in one of two ways.
Either we can take our current home
screen and add the check boxes,
or we can take a look at this calendar
day, see that it has all the same
information as our current home screen,
but also as check boxes, and
say, well, maybe we don't need
actually this home screen anymore.
So instead, I'm going to go through
the hotspots we already have and
change them so that rather than pointing
at home, they point at calendar day.
To do that, I'm first going
to go into this view part.
Then I'm going to click on build mode,
and
that will bring up all the hot spots.
So the way I've done this,
home is the one that currently
points at the home screen.
We want home to point at calendar day,
so we just change that, click save,
and now if we go back to our
preview mode click on home,
it'll bring us to calendar day.
There are two other places we'll need to
do this change, so let's move on through.
The first place is in
your sign up screen.
Usually when you click this create for
create an account, it will link you
to home or to your walkthrough.
You can change that to
calendar day if you'd like.
If you haven't pointed me in
the walkthrough, then you have to change
this to point to calendar day, and
again, every time it's very simple.
Click on this,
click on the drop down, go to
the right screen and then click save.
See, here's our home, we don't actually
have to change anything from this home
to root from the prototype.
All we need to do is change
the things that would otherwise point
to this home screen.
So going through this, it looks like
there aren't any other places where we
know we need to change the hotspot.
There are places where we might
have to change the hotspot.
Depending on how you implemented this
new screen, this create might go to
link back, close, or it might currently
be pointing at the home screen.
Similarly for this back button up here.
Check those before you move on.
The last one is this sign in.
Very often this will be
pointing towards home, and
you'll want this to be
pointing towards calendar day.
With all of that done,
we can go to our preview mode and
click around to be sure
that we've done this right.
So let's try signing in, and wonderful,
now we're on this screen
with the check boxes.
That's what we wanted.
If we take a look at creating a task, we
now see that it does say, in fact, task.
It's a little bit spaced weird,
but it took us five minutes to do.
Wonderful, mow your test
project should have reacted to
all of the feedback we got in our first
round of user testing, which means,
of course, that it's time for
more user testing.